[Musique]
le conseil académique de l'université
paris saclay après l'initiative de
monter un séminaire pour exploiter les
synergies qui peuvent exister sur le
plateau de saclay entre la science la
formation la recherche d'une part et
l'industrie de l'autre de l'autre parent
donc la synergie
elle se fait pas tout seul il faut une
incitation une incitation au réseau et
savoir quels quel type d'incitation on
peut proposer pour que ça fonctionne et
comment les acteurs eux mêmes doivent
s'organiser au jour le jour
pour réaliser ces synergies et et
innover innover davantage sur le plateau
de saclay
cette journée est bâtie à partir de 7
cette question de questionnements qui
peuvent s'adresser
aux chercheurs académiques ou aux
personnes de terrain
[Musique]
sur le plateau de saclay il ya déjà un
écosystème d'innovation qui a été créée
avec des investissements publics des
aides publiques notamment on peut citer
la sat qui est une société des deux
transferts technologiques qui fait
partie du réseau national des sacs qui
va aider des projets innovants à trouver
leur place il y à aussi dans le réseau
pépite nationale le réseau qui associé à
saclay caps est ce qui pour aider les
étudiants qui ont une idée
pour créer leur start up on va les aider
donc on fait passer comme ça de la
formation jusqu'à la création
d'entreprise start up il y à de
nombreuses incubateur il ya des fab lab
et il y à des fonds des fonds
d'investissements des fonds des
financements et comme là qui vient
d'être mis en eau mis en place avec 150
millions d'euros de financement pour les
idées innovantes et les projets
innovants sur le plateau donc tout ça
c'est en train de se mettre en place
mais il faut il faut continuer à
travailler et à augmenter j'irai encore
les synergies pour devenir vraiment le
cluster innovants au niveau mondial